so the post-millennial Stacy Abrams
not-for-profit launches direct action
against cop City
this is Stacey Abrams who some speculate
will run for president we'll see
encouraging people to join stop cop City
the hashtag used by the terror
organization the terrorists some who are
not even from the United States who fire
bombed cop City and uh were charged with
domestic terrorism
so here's what I find fascinating
we have Whoopi Goldberg saying what
Tucker Carlson did in publishing proof
of the lies from the Democratic party
and the establishment the corporate
press saying that should be illegal
my question is how come no one in the
mainstream press none of the Democrats
and we know the answer of course but my
question is if if we're trying to
approach it logically to ask someone who
is not Discerning or doesn't understand
how come they're screaming j6 while
far-left extremists are firebombing
Atlanta Memphis and this police facility
this government facility when you have
foreign individuals joining this group
and fire bombing equipment and attacking
cops with explosives they're talking
about something that happened two years
ago right there's an Insurrection going
on right now Stacy Abrams organization
is helping organize for the terrorists
they are literally charged with domestic
terrorism right on more than one
occasion they have been charged with
domestic terrorism and Stacy Abrams is
helping and a Southern Poverty Law
Center lawyer was arrested among the
terrorists and the spokesperson for the
splc posted in support of the of the
terrorists right that is not in the
mainstream narrative no
honestly I think that they actually
don't see the things that they do it's
not even necessarily that there's a
double or an intentional double standard
I think that they legitimately don't
think it's a crime when they do it I
think that the the because most of the
time in the is this about racism is this
about social justice the government is
building a large police training
facility and so they want to they
they've burned down private buildings
private homes they've burnt they flipped
the guy's truck over and torched it
these are private citizens right it's
it's just it's just overt Terror
political Terror possibly the argument
that they give is because it's a um is
environmental they don't want to cut
down not completely it's a mix of things
you you've got depending on who they're
talking to they'll argue oh they're
trying to Deforest that's the one then
they'll say oh well it's because cops
are racist oh it's because of police
department defund the police so it's
just basically you have a national
Banner antifa International to be honest
they have uh killed people they've been
expanding and it's it's nowhere to
Nowhere to be seen no one cares right
this is the warning I have for everybody
When Stacy Abrams can have an
organization advocate for and support
overt terrorism I mean come on like
they're literally breaking into a
government compound and setting
equipment on fire and torching it and
there's people from France and Canada
who are along with it like this is these
are foreign individuals in the United
States attacking government property
when that is institutionalized defended
or outright ignored like I gotta say it
sounds like you're losing the right is
losing if antifa can and has gotten away
with murdering people
and burning this stuff down I mean as an
institution as an organization as an
idea
where where where is any kind of
counterance to this so what I mean to
say is Aaron Danielson gets shot and
killed in Portland 30 some odd people in
the Summer of Love riots yes some of
those people who committed those murders
have been brought to justice but as an
ideology black lives matter and antifa
have still not gotten this degree of
scrutiny that January 6 did not even
close and if you remember in 2020 I
believe it was in St Louis when that mob
of black lives matter protesters went to
a gated community they broke the gate
down they rushed inside and a couple
came out on their lawn the McCluskey is
and there's that kind of iconic imagery
of them holding their guns protecting
their property we all know how that that
ended up it was the mccluskeys that
ended up getting arrested it was the
mccluskeys that I believe ended up being
charged and and ended up being the
enemies and the villains in that case
and what's interesting is like on a sort
of macro level it's almost an identical
situation to what happened at the
Capitol I mean you had a mob of people
go into an area where they weren't
supposed to be if the mccluskeys were
like the Capitol Police protecting the
building why are the Capitol Police the
the victims in the January so which you
know by the way they are but like why
are the mccluskeys the villains for
protecting their property in that
situation I warned everybody in 2018 I
said
sooner or later
these far left extremists will come to
your home and the cops will sit there
and say it is easier to arrest the
homeowner than it is to deal with a riot
yeah and we've seen it on multiple
occasions the mccloskeys are a good
example they break onto private property
onto the actual lawn of their building
yeah and the mccloskeys who own legal
weapons come out brandishing them saying
get off our property
mccloskeys are the ones who actually are
criminally charged right you have the
story out of Milwaukee where they these
these BLM writers who had burned down
someone else's house or I should say set
someone else's house on fire twice show
up in front of his house he brandishes a
shotgun through his window the cops come
and arrest him in his own home
I'm sorry man like maybe I'm completely
wrong to say Civil War and it's more
like the revolution is happening it's
been happening it will continue to
happen and sooner or later you will owe
nothing and you will be well you'll be
very unhappy but don't worry the
government will give you pills or
they'll flog you unless you say you're
happy you know
um after I got arrested and got out of
jail you know I started reading the
eight page press release that the FBI
wrote on my case and and submitted to
the media and then the 30-page
sentencing recommendation that the
government created on my Class B
misdemeanor and in it they went through
my social media and pulled a great
number of tweets and things like that to
sort of substantiate you know this
person's a lunatic with violent
tendencies and look at these things that
he said and they actually pulled a tweet
where I had said I said make your piece
right now with the fact that we're in a
civil war we didn't want it we didn't
ask for it but it's here and at this
point you better kind of open your eyes
and and see what's happening they're
like you know he's promoting promoting
Civil War this guy is danger address and
I had to kind of explain to them number
one if you look carefully I'm saying
it's already here it's someone else
started it's at your doorstep but number
two when I talk about a modern Civil War
and I think when we talk about a modern
Civil War we're not talking about like
grabbing your musket and taking out to
the streets and starting and shooting
people we're talking about debanking
people freezing people from being able
to send and receive money from being
able to exist on social media or exist
in the Public Square destroying people's
reputations but that's all the precursor
the look at look at Civil Wars
throughout history it doesn't start with
one day a guy walk outside and says you
know what I'm just so darn mad at the
president I'm in a civil war and then
the people go outside with guns and
start shooting each other right it
happens because tensions between
factions either ideological political
religions otherwise start bubbling up to
the point where people then say I've had
enough of you you're dangerous when you
see roving bands of far left extremists
going through cities and firebombing
storefronts this is how it starts the
way it starts is this you will have have
a band of Ideal ideological extremists
they will grow their ideology it will
it'll it'll percolate down through the
masses throughout the entire country
they'll put up a banner they'll identify
each other they'll recruit one day the
extremists will commit very serious
crimes the police the government or
locals will defend against those crimes
killing one of the extremists the
extremists will use that as evidence
among their cult that they are being
victimized and must fight back with
violent Force
take a look at what happened in Georgia
far left extremists occupying a forest
opened fire on police officers shooting
one of them
these people had burned down private
homes already literally torched houses
they were they were under construction
for sale houses I don't think people
lived in there they stopped a guy who
was in his truck a regular old dude
booted him out and flipped it over and
set it on fire
ideological extremists then when the
police get shot at they return fire
killing one of the extremists the
corporate press and the activists then
say the police assassinated one of our
our members a peaceful peaceful
environmental activist was was brutally
murdered by the police and the guardian
was my favorite they said the police
provided no evidence that he was shot
the officer said to be in stable
condition in the hospital it's like okay
so the cop got shot by this guy
so we're at that point where there is no
right-wing equivalent to antifa no the
closest you ever got was proud boys and
the proud boys were so smart that when
they got into a fight with antifa they
walked up to the cops and said here's my
name and information thanks officer and
the cops slapped cuffs on him and put
him in prison for four years
congratulations the closest thing you
can even get to any anywhere near it is
January 6 which is yes a riot some a lot
of people in the front of the building
violent and then a lot of people on the
other side of the building being let in
and what happens the federal government
pulls out all the stops to destroy
anyone in any way associated with that
day if they can if they can do you think
it's hard for the public to believe that
there can be left-wing domestic
terrorists because I think back to all
the environmental groups in the 70s that
re erect have everywhere you know they
were extremely active they burned
buildings they broke into places like
it's actually normal for domestic
terrorism to be perpetrated by the left
but it seems like because they were the
party of like peace and love and hippies
somehow we like like forget to say oh
wait they can also have extreme I I
think it's a combination of far left far
left extremists know they're lying you
know we were talking earlier I can't
remember who said they don't think it's
what they're doing is illegal they know
what they're doing is illegal they don't
care they think they are morally
justified in committing crimes against
other people maybe that's a better way
to say it yeah maybe that's a better way
to say it because that I was going to
give the same answer that I gave earlier
which is that most of the time that
there's violent extreme extremism that
comes from the left it's often some way
rooted to some sort of social injustice
which often is tied to race and anytime
the topic of race is involved it seems
like anything goes and anything can be
justified I mean you can literally Loot
and kill and and beat people up and burn
p and burn buildings down and if people
like us say what the hell is going on
people say oh these people have been
experiencing Injustice for Generations
whether even when you're whether it's
race or whether it's LGBT issues or
whether it's class it's all or it's
always a trojan horse for some type of
Oppression and it's always going to be
moving leftwards we live in the logic of
Herbert Marcus you can read about this
Herbert Mark Hughes wrote it up in a an
essay from the 60s called on tolerance
or pure tolerance
um and essentially it says it's okay for
the left to do whatever it's
consequentialism it's just they're
looking for a result which is their
policies
instituted and if their policies fail
that's fine because it moves the
dialectic along that's all it is it's
let the the left is entirely built on a
dialectic uh a a dialectic system so as
long as they can imp Implement their
policies they're fine with lying they're
fine with whatever whatever means
because at the at their core they're not
liberals they don't believe in in
individual rights the way that we do
they don't believe that the rights that
you have come from your Humanity or from
God or whatever they believe that all
rights come from the state that means
that your rights are just gifts so
there's no reason to argue about that
you have the right for this or you have
the right for that you have whatever
right the state says I think those
ideologies are not as relevant as a lot
of people think they're certainly
wielded as a weapon to guide and control
these masses but I I believe that the
far left extremists are chaos and
nothing more
soldiers yeah but the people that are
the people that are calling the shots
the people that are that are that are
informing the ideas that are writing the
books that that that are teaching
children these people are are religious
fundamentalists I disagree I I think
that the reason they're going after kids
with this gender ideology stuff and the
far left stuff is literally just to
destroy them you don't have a child
sterilize themselves if you're trying to
create an army or to control a machine
because you're cutting the you're
cutting the root out from the plant you
need what what is what is the out the
outcome of all this will be the complete
destruction of the west of of American
culture in which case
exactly so that that there's not going
to be any kind of communist Utopia
there's not going to be equality there's
going to be burning rubble and they
won't be here they'll be in China so
they use leftist ideology in my opinion
as a means to an end but if you actually
had people adhering to a structure of
this ideology there would be a structure
to it however what we end up seeing is
there's no ideology they change things
on a whim one day it's wimix in next day
it's women with a Y one day it's it's
women now the joke is women plus yeah
that's a good one women plus so if if
there was a consistency to their
ideology and goals I would agree they
actually believe this stuff but but
watching this stuff over the past 10
years and seeing there is no
start point and end point I'm like oh
all it is is a chaotic destructive force
that spreads and consumes and destroys
the the chaos is the chaos is
intentional because like I said there
like I said before that happy people
don't are like happy societies don't
have a lot of revolutions if you have a
society that's working with people that
have that trust each other with a high
trust Society where you have where you
don't have significant amounts of of
economic disparity and you have
everybody feeling like they kind of have
the same culture and the same kind of or
at least are free to express their
cultures you don't need a revolution you
don't need to tear everything down but
if you have enough people that feel like
they are unhappy with their lives
they're unhappy with their station for
whatever reason whether it be because
they they believe they live in the wrong
they were born in the wrong body or they
believe that that they live in a white
supremacist Society or whether they
believe that that the man is the reason
that they can't get ahead and it's it's
the rich people blah blah whatever
reason you can use to sow Discord in the
society is the in intent and the goal
because the Discord makes people want to
revolt they don't want to Revolution
that way but there is a an inconsistency
as it applies to uh political lines
because they they don't embrace the
Discord or the the sense of Oppression
when it comes to issues that bother
people on the right I mean yeah if you
go back and you look at 2020 again and
you know black lives matter and all the
destruction that was done in the name of
racial justice but they can't seem to
wrap their head around why anybody would
become inflamed to commit violence on
January 6th so the question that I've
always wondered is and I don't condone
the the violence of January 6 I never
have but the question is why is it okay
to commit violence because black people
some black people feel like they're
having some kind of experience in this
country that is unsatisfying to them but
you can't rep your head around the fact
that there's an enormous group of people
who believe that their election and
their vote was being stolen and that
they thought that a fake president was
being installed through a stolen
election its intentional hierarchy
there's the in-group in the out group
The Communist the party like the
Democrats whatever whatever you want to
call them if you want to call them
Democrats doesn't matter but the point
is if you're in the in-group they make
whatever excuses for your behavior if
you're in the out group then you're then
you're not even a person like right
we're going through like a maoist style
Cultural Revolution and if you go back
and listen to Mao's uh speeches or read
his speeches he talks about like the
people and the the democracy and that's
only applied to the the actual people
that are in the party everyone else is
the enemy and that's the dynamic that we
have here when the Democrats talk about
we're worried about our democracy they
are talking about the Democrats and the
Democrats only when they're talking and
everyone that's trying to destroy our
democracy are the people that are trying
to do things that the Democrats don't
want if you do things the Democrats
don't want that is destroy our democracy
when they say we that is not referring
to you yeah it's referring to them
exactly thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time